Britney Spears stage crasher body
slammed by Security+ million dollar
Matchmaker Patti Stanger is here and we
are putting that John and Chrissy scale
to some good news
hey friends this is the daily Benny and
we've got our very first in-studio guest
today Patti Stanger of we TV's a million
dollar matchmaker
she spilled the tea on some of
Hollywood's biggest couples but first
someone's checked on Britney Spears
there was some drama during Brits Las
Vegas show last night when a man rushed
the stage
well actually was more of like a drunk
cartwheel but you see for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay all kidding aside that is scary you
can see Brittany's knees buckle and then
she asked if a man had a gun ultimately
backup dancers helped kick the guy down
and one dancer told ichi they actually
built a barrier between him and brittany
so don't mess with Brett especially when
it comes to her dancers eventually the
man was restrained and kicked out of the
concert he was booked by Las Vegas
police for trespassing now an eye
witness tells ET the suspect was acting
rowdy all night he was seen climbing
over chairs and security asked him to
calm down several times before he
stormed the stage another concert goer
said the audience was very supportive of
Brittany yelling leave Brittany alone
and cussing out the guy thankfully for
those fans Brittany was whisked away for
about five minutes before she came back
and finished the show alright but moving
on if you're rich famous and single
first of all thank you for watching this
second of all you might want to seek
advice from Love Guru and we TVs
million-dollar Matchmaker Patti Stanger
I sat down with her today to get her
take on Hollywood's hottest couples you
know we follow celebrity celebrity
couples so closely on this show and the
rate by which we rate them is one to ten
time being John Legend and Chrissy
Teigen so first of all do you agree John
and Chrissy are like the ultimate
celebrity couple go on I kind of yeah
that's probably a 10 probably a 10 he
loved her to death and she loved him to
death and they did goofy together I've
seen them that Lady Gaga's birthday
party you know they're they're like kind
of normal she was like nine months
pregnant and dancing on the table or
something like she's just like they're
really real people and he's so talented
and she's so beautiful so yeah I got get
him up I live for them so that being
said I'm going to give you a list of
celeb couples reach them from 1 to 10 10
being Johnny don't hate me after that
here we go John and Chrissy scale JLo
and Iran oh that's an 8 oh good it can
be a 10 I wanted to put a ring on it and
don't look at anyone else love that Mila
Kunis and Ashton Kutcher oh that's a
tenth that's as well okay I called that
that needed to check Bravo
many years ago when he broke up with
Jimmy I was the one who said he needed
to go out to the tennis and all over the
news so I gave it a 12
that's all you patty yeah Blake Lively
and Ryan
um good ten I think I have issues but I
think they worked him at the virgo
Scorpio match they live in New York
they're out of the scene I can do a good
nine ten I've changed things to yeah I
feel pretty open she tells like what is
bad and was good and he had scarlet so I
didn't really appreciate her I love that
Bachelorette Rachel Lindsey and Brian
Abu solo okay this is a good eight I see
them as a ten when they cross the finish
line to marriage but I think she's going
to do it and as long as she appreciates
him it's going to be fun he adores her
and finally Briah carrie and dancer
slash created by writer Brian's not got
to I mean like come on you know when you
play with the young kids and you're
going towards fifty you're going to get
what you pay for it I want to see miss
Donna settle down okay I mean stop
taking the 25 of it I know they're hot
you know but you don't see me taking em
boys and I could take games from The
Bachelor any day okay it's like you
can't really go there like that you have
to take people's hen the rules are ten
years below and ten years of us that is
it I'm taking notes I hope you guys are
writing spread the last four two laps
off-camera patty actually try to set me
up you guys so here comes my ten ring by
spring folks all right remember that
time you turn 20 and you spend your
birthday hanging out with Kendrick Lamar
seeing your boyfriend's concert and then
hanging out in West Hollywood with their
friends and family where they made a
giant ice sculpture of Djibouti of
course you don't because you're not
Kylie Jenner she just celebrated the end
of her teenage years with her ultra
famous family including Kim and Khloe
Kardashian and her aforementioned
boyfriend Travis Scott at Hills
penthouse and West Hollywood on Thursday
night the surprise party also featured a
pretty hilarious looking cake with
Kylie's face on it look at all old
school Miley and guests like ASAP rocky
and BFF Jordan woods as well as Khloe's
boyfriend Tristan who got an eyeful of
his dates loca ensemble which according
to Kim K's Instagram turned him into a
cartoon dog meanwhile Kylie can already
planned her retirement as experts are
saying her makeup brand Kylie cosmetics
has sold 420 million dollars in just 18
months and is well on its way to being a
billion dollar brand
meaning she'll never have to work
another day in her life
damn when I was 20 I was crammed into a
house with eight other dudes in college
and regretting not studying abroad so
you know pretty much the same and
apparently her sister Khloe agrees that
the rest of the fam are now dead to
momager Kris Jenner I cuz that is it for
today be sure to LIKE comment and share
this video plus Patti Stanger has plenty
more to dish on including the split from
her pal Chris Pratt and Anna Faris the
full interview is up now and tonight on
YouTube I grab the dance out i'ma do
single ladies because I'm not gonna be
single for too long yeah Patti